well I'm joined now by the well probably
the most famous journalist in the
country today Ava Santina a tour TV
contributor Esther Krakow and the
associated to the mirror Kevin McGuire
okay
elephant in the room time Ava sent it
well but nothing else I've discovered
something today the Ava 17 is your first
name and Evans is your surname yeah I
don't know quite why we've called you by
your gloriously double-barreled first
name as if that's your whole name anyway
they've been overly polite and just yeah
so now I've been reading all about this
journalist called uh Ava Evans I thought
who's that yeah so first of all we're
going to start calling you by a proper
name um
this has been a really difficult time
for you the last 24 hours and I was
watching all this happen in real time
last night with this GB new situation
where Lawrence Fox who I think is a
repulsive individual the best of times
decided to personally Target you in a
really horrible manner uh in a sexually
degrading Manner and he did it on Dan
wooden show uh on GB news as a result
they've both been suspended by GB news
um which is their action it's nobody
else's people are saying well you know
what about cancel culture well they've
been canceled at the moment by their own
network right so
first of all how are you no I'm good you
were one of the first big journalists to
message me last night and I really
really appreciated it um I I think you
know the support has been really really
lovely to see but you know also this
isn't really about me at all I just so
happened to be the person that they
picked on that night and he went too far
with I think I'm I was it wasn't a goal
of mine to get them suspended from the
program but look I I just think that
that that network is is out of hand and
it really needed a bit of a slap down
and I'm sorry that it's happened the way
it has but I'm glad it's happened Dan
wouldn't a presenter who's seen kind of
laughing along with it
um although he looks a little
uncomfortable actually towards the end
of it
um despite that he then tweeted you
personally expressing you know his
apologies and regret and wished he
hadn't done it and said he didn't find
it amusing and then Lawrence Fox tweeted
revealing their text exchange is showing
that Dan did appear to found it funny do
you see them in two different categories
here or accomplices to the same problem
um I I would I would say that Dan
wouldn't facilitated it and he's an
experienced broadcaster and he should
have shut it down I also think that the
people in the gallery should have shut
it down you know they should have gone
above and beyond but look I think you
know last night Dan Wootton did try to
call me many many times and I didn't
take the phone call and I I didn't take
the phone call because I thought perhaps
the truth will come out the next day and
I'd rather not I'd rather not subject
myself to a false apology and judging by
the voicemail he left me and the truth
that has come out today it would have
been a false apology
I think we've got the clip for those who
haven't been following this it's been
gaining more traction through the day
let's look at actually what was said
we're past award shed so I can say this
um show me a single self-respecting man
that would like to climb into bed with
that woman ever
and she sat there and I'm going like if
I met you in a bar and that was like
sentence three chances of me just
walking away are just huge we don't need
these sort of feminist 4.0 they're
pathetic and embarrassing who'd want to
add that
Esther I can see you literally sort of
gulping in horror and what you're
watching and hearing there and it was
just incredibly offensive look I think
Fox is long ago across the the rubric I
remember first watching him when he was
on question time and actually I thought
he I quite supported him at the time uh
over what went down on question time at
time but ever since there's been this
descent into just trying to be as
appalling as he could possibly be and
trying to pretend well you know it's
free speech that is not what protecting
Free Speech should be about that kind of
stuff has no place on any network I mean
this this individual is mentally unwell
and I I think for me what I find the
most disappointing is the fact that Dan
didn't shut it down immediately I mean
when he said you know climb into bed
with with this person I just thought
excuse me what that's that's not your
place that's completely inappropriate
and as an experienced broadcast he
should have said actually you cannot
come on my show and say that that's how
that conversation should have gone he
shouldn't have been allowed to finish
that sentence I mean that's just
horrific
um but ultimately I think what we're
seeing here is someone who exists just
in an echo chamber we talk about people
being an echo chamber Twitter and on
social media but actually there's a real
thought of being in the network chamber
in your own personal life as well and
that's something that unfortunately can
happen quite easily in this industry
especially when you wedge yourself
amongst people that have one particular
view on any issue and that's what we're
seeing manifest today he's a grown man
he has children thank God he doesn't
have daughters but at the end of the day
he should know that that's completely
inappropriate Kevin he's shown zero
remorse Lawrence Fox I mean damn what to
his credit and this has shown a lot of
remorse I say to his credit he shouldn't
have done what happened but he has at
least said it was completely wrong I
apologize and so on none of that from
Lawrence Fox he's just dug down ever
deeper and said no I absolutely stand by
everything I say yeah It prepares
revolutions devour their own children
and here you've got the culture war
warriors falling out because Fox is
going to take down wooden that's what
he's done uh and it's interesting I
didn't know you'd received Ava a phone
message from him all full of Contrition
which then he's messaging Fox to someone
else but no fox fox is violent and it's
what happens when you just get cheered
by a small segment of the country yeah
Fox can go around he can get a crowd on
Twitter or on TV but they're the same
people and you just lose touch with
reality
yeah I also think the the what happens
is people start to seek ever greater
highs they're like drug addicts yeah
right so it's kind of diminishing
returns you go down these rabbit holes
you have these wackos following you and
to feed that wacko Beast you have to say
ever more outrageous things and you just
lose all sense of decency and what he
said last night about Ava was just it
was just indecent it was just horrible
to listen to we can all agree on that
you know if this was said now on this
show there'd be outraged quite rightly I
think that a channel has a wider problem
the number of uh conspiracy theorists
and people who are quite frankly nutty
there's almost one channel during the
day and another in the in the evening
where and you know they're all on their
dodgy site shouting about the Deep state
or whatever it is
I like your new name I'm giving you uh
um
have you been on the on the flip side of
this has it been
a nice experience for you to see the
huge reaction from journalists across
the divide in this country male female I
mean I've been I've noticed it myself
just the volume of people racing to
support you I'm very appreciative of it
but I'm I'm really embarrassed by all
about today I'm not really on my phone
very much and I think you know I've
never ever not wanted to do a debate
especially on this program I will debate
anything and you know vociferously I
will do it but this this is now like
about my body and about my just my my
physical being and it's just giving me
this sort of really icky horrible
feeling that I can't quite explain yeah
I get it let's move on to something else
yeah let's let's get out of this
um let's move on actually to do you know
what let's move on to this chocolate one
of my favorite subjects this is a Galaxy
bar
uh it's not as big as it used to be but
it's more expensive and Mars have now
admitted the scam they've cut the bars
and they've upped the price are we all
as outraged as I am about this it's for
our health peers it's to keep us nice
and healthy you have a smaller bit of
this nice it's basically a salad really
because it's coming from a cocoa pod so
it's a salad with a bit of your thinking
it's a salad exactly but you can't have
too much salad it's like a decadent
salad so they have to shrink it to keep
you know everything healthy and yeah the
NHS functioning you know they've also
done it with Weetabix so explain that
what's that about you know that's like
me striving to be healthy every morning
and now I'm getting a smaller portion of
it yes it's an old come from companies
look Mars exists to make lots of money
and here they're going to charge you
more for less it's how capitalism works
but it feels really really sneaky the
biggest chocolate story for me is that
the the dark Bounty chocolate the red
ones actually discontinued temporarily
right and I I they're my favorite thing
so my you know the lovely carry that you
all know who makes everything happen in
my world here she just had to come in
the other day looking really upset and
for all like somebody had died and I
said what's the matter who's died and
she said no it's the Bounty bars have
done I went what she said they're not
making them anymore I was like this
can't be happening so I've always a
campaign Emily matless and others have
joined in um but on a positive note
celebrations those big mixed boxes of
chocolates they stopped putting the
Bounty bars in the Milky ones and so now
because of an outraged response they've
now come up with a bounty only box of
celebrations so I think this is a start
but they're the wrong ones what we need
is a special box of the red ones you're
never happy oh yeah well you know what I
don't ask so much in life honestly I'm
easily pleased Kerry will tell you I'm
easily pleased I've never heard of
anyone eating a dark Bounty I get it all
I want is I want about three or four
cups of tea when I get here as I monitor
my notes and prepare for you special
guests and so on and then I want to have
a dark red Bounty yeah currently I can't
because they have been discontinued
first world problems
miles are watching this I need them to
understand just what this is doing to me
it's actually seemingly slightly
crackers so I need I need to have that
um good to see you all uh Ava I'm very
sorry that you went through that thank
you I really am you had the full support
of all of us here yeah at talk TV not
just on this show I think we all you
know we hugely value your contributions
as a journalist and we'll continue to do
so thank you and uh I'm sorry you went
through it but I'm also gratified that
most right-minded people in our
profession were as outraged as I was and
you guys were and everybody else was so
we move on
good to see you